brush your teeth with nothing using
colorless flavorless nihilist toothpaste
after eating a delicious bag of chirps
the protein-rich snack made out of beans
rice and crickets because it's episode
46 of Luke wake up dressed in your bed
with the wearable futon air mattress and
then strap on a pair of rocket skates
electric motorized skates that fit with
almost any shoe allow you to go up to 12
miles per hour they're controlled by
tilting your feet which means they're
hands-free great news for anyone with
giant lobster claws for hermit crabs
looking to upgrade their digs glass
shell calm cells hand-blown glass shells
which are made to accommodate the
contours of a crabs exoskeleton a body
snap together a gummy bear skeleton
which features detachable organs and a
removable skull cap to see the gummy
bear brain get grumpy thoughts out of
your brain and onto the pages of a grump
notebook a set of three including daily
disappointments things that annoy me and
fresh rants to smell fresh and stay
organized use shower squids that hold
shampoo and soap bottles and for
something smelly that holds pretty much
anything there's orange cream scented
duct tape tape together your own
cardboard mask by following instructions
from winter croft download a PDF of
plans to transform recycled boxes into a
3d cat owl or storm trooper then check
out your new face in the lucid mirror
which contains a luminous 3d image of
celestial clouds hanging in the
reflection hang beer and save space in
your fridge with bottle loft the world's
first magnetic bottle hanger for your
fridge if you're more of a milk drinker
light up your lactose using the glass of
milk light that perfectly pairs with
midnight cookie dunking sessions
courtesy of Dunkin buddy a device that
saves dunked cookies from breaking and
getting lost in your cup pizza smelly
pan pancakes belly pan cotton candy
smelly pan ubi is an always-on
voice-activated computer that you simply
plug in and talk to and it does the
following voice-enabled
internet search speaker
Holmes speaker system voice memos
virtual assistant alarm clock intercom
baby monitor thermostat and noise
pollution monitor so for just one
example if you're baking you can say
okay Ruby remind me in 20 minutes to
take the cake out of the oven and ubi is
pretty much like okay cool no problem
you man I got this because I a movie and
this is an Indiana Jones cat bridge
bridge your love of candy with your
penchant for mystery by getting a Japan
crate in the mail each month a box of
assorted Japanese candies show up on
your doorstep that contains anything
from do-it-yourself sushi candy to
vanilla ice cream Kit Kats then give
yourself a break from cheap razors and
shaved like a barber with the beluga
razor a single edge exposed blade housed
in premium stainless steel that lets you
shave like an old school barber shave
yourself from jaws with shark repellent
and start the countdown on your time
bomb kitchen timer because we're almost
ready to ride off into the sunset on a
motorized monocycle
but make sure you remember that zombies
give the best free hugs and as always
thanks for watching